china
mexicans the rapist the greatest
the greatest i love mexicans they're
rapists
all right welcome everybody it's so
great to see all of you here we are
standing by for a donald trump rally as
if there were no pandemic
in pennsylvania um it looks like people
are getting
pretty excited about something i don't
know if it's air force one
getting uh in the area potentially or
maybe just an american flag exciting
people we have a bloomberg feed
we have a fox news feed we have a pbs
news feed so from the standpoint of
feeds
we're doing a lot of feeding let me put
it that way and
i do hope as many of you are pointing
out oh there's a plan okay no it was a
spirit airlines plane apparently that
got re people really really wound up
seeing spirit air land in these times
was very
exciting for people um i do hope that it
rains
because donald trump keeps these super
short when it rains which i love
so i'm glad you're here scheduled for
the top of the hour and i wanted at
least 20 minutes and it could be hours
depending on how on how late donald
trump is running
i wanted time to go over some different
things with you guys because there is
just i have so much
going on from the standpoint of memes
videos images um
there's an interesting post claiming
that i'm autistic now that's a new one
that's not one that i've heard before
but we're going to go over that and
there's just a lot i do want to give a
little bit of time for people
to connect and to join in so i'm just
going to read a few super chats and
subscription messages and different
things
and i will do new member thank yous we
have a very modest goal of 25
by popular demand we're keeping twitch
subscribers up on the screen as you can
see we have dipped down
below 1300 from our historic high of
about 14.50
so let's just jump into some super chats
and see what what's on people's minds
and then i'm going to get to the memes
and different things
chaka seki says have you heard the
latest conspiracy theory it's called
blue chew anon it's really getting a
rise
out of the radical left i see what you
did there
chaka seki also says beware everyone if
trump wins 2020 he could appoint many
more conservative judges
to the supreme court yes a lot of soup
related controversy who knew bisques and
chowders could be so
divisive in america as we launch
a hype train leaving the station tariq
dc
has subscribed on twitch henny baked ham
has subscribed with the message keep it
up
tan man is now at 14 months somehow tan
man has been subscribed for 14 months
and i've only been on twitch for 13
months i don't know how you've managed
to do it tan man but i love it
and cho wes has subscribed with the
message
love the content david please keep it up
you're a
huge contribution toward a better
society
here is the spirit airplane coming by
and people i've never seen people go so
crazy about an airplane from spirit
landing
i think i just saw a woman rip a sink
out of the wall she was so fired up by
it
the feed here from bloomberg
is not great so we're going to go over
to other feeds as soon as they're
available and in fact
let's see if the white house feed
is now live because i would prefer
to be perfectly frank i would prefer
that feed
doesn't look like they are live yet okay
so we'll keep it going all right
other super chats coming in corey price
says try and fail but don't fail to try
a bag of soup i've lived by that for a
long time
c says did you happen to record your
reactions to the 2008 or 2004 election
if so i'm sure the audience would like
to see it that would be interesting
well i wasn't live during the 2008
election but you can find video from the
day after
for sure on my youtube channel jake
says when i was little i was hazed by
having soup bags dispersed in my general
direction
boy did they have force that's what i've
read
chris says ah okay i'm ready for this
now
ross pagarian says trump is the spirit
airlines of presidents well
said very much well said unknown prodigy
lets us know that they're eating
pistachio nuts you know i don't know
calling them pistachio nuts seems um
unnecessary they're just pistachios
as far as i know them uh thanks to tic
tac
tacos for subscribing on twitch
zombarilla
has subscribed new 02wrx has subscribed
and crazy hawaiian has subscribed on
twitch with the message
hi all thanks for the coverage david
thank you for being here i do have a
donald trump sound board some of you may
have heard this earlier
i don't know if it's useful for the
streams but let's listen to a few things
to do something with china economically
also china the power we have
yeah um what else do i have don't be
rude
okay four united states marines are now
dead
okay that doesn't seem to this isn't
this doesn't seem like the best sound
board
uh like china like china
no words i have the best words yeah i
don't know that that's really useful for
the type of stream that i do
i've been encouraged by people on on
soundboards
i just don't know i'm just not sure
mexico
maybe for making our products
stealing our companies and destroying
our
jobs if they had god bless the united
states
i would like that let's see if i can
find that
no they don't even have that i don't
know i'm gonna get away from the sound
board i don't i don't think it's
super useful for what we're doing i do
want to say thanks to david
seeley david seeley is new member
number one today our single solitary new
member
at joinpakman.com all right let's get
into some of the fun
okay guys i've got a bunch of different
things here to show you
uh let's see what we've got okay david
didn't choose
thug life the thug life chose him
this is a screenshot of my face i don't
know from when
but it's not bad i appreciate that
somebody put this together for me very
important
we do have a new meme template this is
from my
instagram from this morning as many of
you know i've been prepping
for some time now and i posted a picture
on my instagram which is david.pacman
this is me
with a medical kit as well as a headlamp
and my instinct my instinct is that this
may be memeable
if you decide to do anything with this
please please please
send it to me through the website
contact form
we are at the stage of the stream where
people ask if i pay attention to twitch
it happens every stream so let me
mention that yes i do
uh thank you other things this is
something somebody put together
i guess there's a there's concern in the
destiny community
and by and i mean stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell the second
or kenny two as i know him there's
concern that i
that we're having an issue i guess
because he said something crazy about
kenosha although i haven't heard it yet
and this i guess is people want to save
the bridge between the two
communities the david pakman show
community and the stephen kenneth
destiny banel the second community
and you see kenneth next to i think this
is a ford focus
with a license plate that says coomer
and then this is me next to a tesla
model 3
with a license plate that says boomer so
this is pretty well done
i have to tell you and the rest in peace
hassan
flag or banner in the background
things are on fire very well done really
really good
execution um
then we've got oh okay this is a post
speaking of kenneth this is a post which
seems to be serious let me just make
sure we're not missing anything over
here
still no trump okay good i don't want to
miss a minute of the idiocy
at trump's rally um this is a post from
this
from the destiny subreddit which was so
dumb that i felt
like i had to respond to it um
does david have aspergers moderators
will probably delete this
but i am genuinely curious david has
always seemed
a little off he doesn't seem to grasp
humor or internet culture at
all i have rarely seen him display
emotion or interpret things
non-literally
logically i would ask in his subreddit
but i don't want to hurt his feelings
no no no um i my feelings would
certainly not be hurt and i
this was so dumb i had to come in and
comment myself and i put
no i'm not autistic i find it funny to
pretend not to understand internet
culture since it's become a
self-perpetuating meme that i don't
understand it
some of my viewers find it funny too at
least one person
interprets it as autism which is true
and it's this person right here
now some people i i understand some
people might not realize that
there were a few instances where i
pretended not to have any idea
what things meant like once i got a
super chat and i pretended
uh i i pronounced a dragon ball z
character as
vegida and said i hope it's not some
kind of like racist vegetarian thing
or something like that and people found
it funny so i just deadpan it that's all
it is but i know that
i guess at least one person thought it
could be autism
but it is not it is not and if i if i
was on the spectrum i would have no
problem telling you guys
corinne erickson is new member number
two today
at joinpakman.com i appreciate that
very very much i really do um nathaniel
booth has come in out of nowhere with a
super chat
says david i'm supporting you through
super chat because i'm afraid
i might be arrested for becoming a
website member that low price has to be
illegal
yeah so there's something going on right
now we have our
i've never mentioned this before okay so
people might not know this
but our number one funding source
is website memberships so this is
somebody who says
i'm clicking around on the internet i go
to joinpackman.com and i get a
membership
okay that's our primary funding source
the discount that i'm currently offering
see where it says 2020 now
for 66 percent off that discount
i don't know if it's illegal it's
certainly immoral
it's a it's certainly immoral but i
understand the concern nathaniel worried
that it might be an illegal website
membership discount but i
invite you to try it i don't think
you'll get arrested and i will thank you
on stream and we will slowly
fill up this bar hopefully all the way
up to 25 so feel free to take advantage
of that
coupon code 2020 now i think it'll
you'll do really well with it steven
robbins is here
also known as ronald reagan with the
message
d-man it's ray gun what kind of super
chat do i need to send to get you on my
podcast redirect
immigration law and perspectives oh i
don't know you know i'm really limiting
the amount of
uh other media that i'm doing right now
because i'm just
so busy we're getting ready to go on on
our sort of last vacation
uh before we power all the way through
to election day we've just lost the feed
from pennsylvania but i think it'll come
back
um so i'm really limiting my my uh what
i would call
foreign podcast appearances and by
foreign i mean outside of my show
however for people who have been
demanding the spanish language content
i did a two days ago record a one hour
episode
for a spanish language podcast and when
it's
live i will upload it to my youtube
channel
and i will subtitle it for everybody so
even non-spanish speakers
are going to be able to uh to enjoy it i
don't know what's going on now with the
feed we had this problem yesterday
during donald trump's event
uh please monitor website for upcoming
oh boy
let's see uh trump pennsylvania live
oh my god everything's going wrong trump
pennsylvania live
let's see what we've got and let's
filter for live
i have other feeds going
and of course i should i should spell
these things correctly
pennsylvania live
bloomberg that's where we were let's
restrict it just to live results
if we can bloomberg we don't want to do
local
news here's my stream oh the hill okay
the hill's pretty reliable
whoa oh my god
uh okay all right we're back and waiting
for donald trump very good you don't
worry we're not we're not gonna miss
anything
so anyway thanks stephen i'll i'll
consider uh podcast appearances
upcoming at some point relatively soon
i think that'll be a really interesting
thing to do
okay um kyle hopper says do you think
it's plausible
that trump will be china dog whistle to
white supremacists at this event i
believe so
i believe so and in fact since kyle
popped in
maybe i will give you guys another
preview of the david plosman shuffle
this is going to be debuted in full
during our vacation
but uh this is from kyle hopper who just
sent a super chat this is one of my
favorite
ancillary pieces of content take a look
at this
uh let's see what else we've got here
the david pakman
[Music]
so well done
so you've heard me say it this is not a
rehearsal
very very important stuff because this
could get really ugly really quickly
yep ow now
[Music]
the big big big big big big question
you all see what's going on i see what's
going on we're not going to fall for it
these bizarre
semantic games philosophical black holes
that people are getting we're just not
going to bite
[Music]
i would return the ballot as soon as
possible
if you're mailing it if you have the
ability to drive it to a ballot box
i would do that as well and that's
actually my plan do it all make sure you
have a plan that makes sense
based on what's happening in your state
based on where you can drop off ballots
in your state
and don't make your plan on the basis of
a false sense of security from
this announcement that's the most
important message right
and very important
the purdy shuffle hard to beat it
we have to just vote early early early
but it's too close
it's too risky we really need donations
of the plasma
tea and i will have to make a decision
about how and when i send in my ballot
and assume nothing going into november
every single voter i i
apologize i know i say this a lot every
single voter
should act as if their vote could turn
your state from one candidate to the
other
which is to overwhelm the vote to such a
degree
right that none of these bamboozlings
and lies slows actually help
donald trump to get re-elected i was
born in argentina
[Music]
what we have to make sure we do is to
vote participate keep the pressure on as
far as the post office keep the pressure
on as far as
uh vote by mail right and fundamentally
the question is
do you want to remove trump enough that
you will vote for joe biden
it's going to be a turnout battle yep
and specifically it'll be turned out in
key states
which will decide who wins it's
convalescent plasma
oh man that's that's my favorite moment
at 222. that convalescent plasma gets me
every time who wins
okay so that's that and then we're going
to be
that that's the the full thing is going
to publish during our uh oh there's
trump landing
the full thing is going to publish
during our vacation so that's going to
be upcoming
okay other memes other memes i do have a
few other memes for you guys
this is if i had a child with
alexandria ocasio-cortez
that's a kid who's going places okay
that's a kid with upper management
written all over him and this was sent
to me by a geneticist
oh what oh no it was someone with an app
i'm sorry it was not a geneticist this
is if i had a child
with uh alexandria ocasio-cortez and
that that's a that would be a good kid
i think um very well dressed i have to
say
sharp looking for sure so that was sent
to me
um i got a grudge match meme
image from someone about the race to 1
million
this is pac versus sam the race to 1
million so that's nicely done
and then uh and then the media says this
is just soup
this one i don't really get this one i
don't really get
but it's not i like it but the the big
one is
if i had a kid with alexandria
ocasio-cortez i think that that's really
really good
so thanks to everybody who sent me that
uh
we are waiting for donald trump here
some of these other videos have not yet
gone live but that's okay
um let me get caught up on new members
because we did have a very powerful
influx of new members number three today
is aaron budge
number four is jeff miller number five
is alex liblic liblic is is number five
vince ventura number six douglas brand
is new member number seven on my website
joseph wolfgram is number eight
maura mitchell is number nine thanks to
october primavera love it who is new
member number 10.
nathaniel booth is number 11 and jill
stevens is number 12. so that that's
taking a big chunk out of our goal
uh and also thanks to trevor perry 311
and dr
ravenholm for supporting over on twitch
and just people are just flying in from
everywhere for what will certainly be an
unhinged rally
featuring donald trump one other little
thing to show you guys this is kind of
cool
so as as some of you do in in all
seriousness as i like to say
as donald trump's plane is pulling
around here oh it looks like they
brought the little one is this the 757
yeah probably too small of a runway for
for the big boy
yeah uh we are on track to hit 1 million
youtube subscribers on september 28th
just 24 days from now
check out this beautiful message of
peace and love
that ben dixon has recorded now i've got
about 10 of these or 11 from different
people
you're going to hear from a lot of your
favorite content creators
check out the beautiful message from ben
dixon i'm just going to preview this for
you guys this will be part of our
compilation
david pakman congratulations my friend
on 1
million subscribers that is an awesome
accomplishment that i don't expect to
see
until the year 2220 at the rate that my
youtube channel is growing but i digress
uh but no seriously um david
i want to talk to the audience about
david i don't know talk to many people
uh know this but david actually was one
of the biggest
helps in getting my show off the ground
um when i'm when i lived in boston the
first time
right um david invited me to use his
studio
and we were able to produce with high
quality production
and i mean he just kind of all the way
all the way around the board helped me
out however he could
so um you know shout out to david
congratulations man
um on all your success remember it's a
pre-congratulations but we can't wait
until we hit a million to film these
because then we wouldn't be able to put
them together
and uh just keep doing what you're doing
keep growing keep thriving
and keep quietly helping people um
no telling how many people you've helped
if you haven't talked that i know you
helped a whole lot of people so
it's really it was actually just ben
that i helped but it's very very nice
of him to say all this stuff okay so
anyway that's just like
one preview of what we're putting
together for when we do hit one million
here we have uh okay it looks like we
now have multiple live streams which is
great we're going to stick with the pbs
pbs stream which i like
i can't imagine survive didn't survivor
sue already over using that song
um whatever trump doesn't trump doesn't
care
all right so anyway we're standing by
for trump uh in the 757.
um anybody ever noticed how the 757
looks like it's on stilts you kind of
have to see the front to notice it but
it's quite
quite an odd looking plane um
okay let's see when did i last
fly a 757 i actually remember um
last time i went to la
was it when i did the rogan show i don't
know i flew
on delta boston to lax and it was on a
757 that they were using you know
pre-covered
on international flights as well as
domestic
so yep that's uh that's my story all
right
let's see i got so off track super chats
though i don't want to miss them
i missed a bunch though let's see let me
work up for a moment
stand up and fight back says stand up
and fight back
zest the african says from the
standpoint of radical moderate democrats
how much do you love trump's fear of
rain
it was weird how trump seemed so afraid
of just
just a little rain yesterday it was
unusual
um chris says how much money do these
people pay to see a madman ranting on
stage now tickets for this stuff is
are free these rallies are a modern day
ringling brothers circus that's true
deretend says we need pacman plasma
lo-fi
playlist i'm on it yeah if people want
to do more
of a lo-fi plasma related thing
that is almost guaranteed
to uh to get on the show sean says i'm
enjoying your post
rnc streams and videos quite a bit it
seems those few days off really restored
your energy and mood
yeah the rnc was soul crushing it was
one of the most disgusting political
events
i've ever seen ever ever ever and i am
so glad that it's done
and um it was also just exhausting
um you know trump having to have a
longer
session two and a half hours a day
rather than than two
and it was really really horrible so i'm
so glad it was
it's over thanks to o.g hidden for
subscribing with twitch prime
people asking if i have more memes
i don't really have more memes let me
see
just briefly here let me see if i have
any other let me see
if i can preview any
oh you know what i could preview
let me see here i can preview one more
of the
um i can preview one more of the
congratulatory
videos oh but it looks like things are
going to get moving soon and i won't do
it now i had
i had an interesting a former nfl
football player
gr a great and a former nfl football
player
recorded a very nice message for me with
a pre-congrats
on a million subscribers and maybe i'll
show that to you guys
a little bit later i do want to see how
trump takes the stairs here that's
always a real question mark
other super super chats are coming in
like a faucet i really appreciate it
uh jake says make america plasma soup
that sounds nice there was actually a
soup related
message i missed let me see if i can
find it
uh where was it
evan field says 499 says we get low
energy
slurring trump for some reason you know
yesterday i predicted upper trump
i do think it might be downer trump
today i do
tristan mccoppen says i'm eating
pistachio clam chowder that's nice
unknown prodigy says are these idiots
seriously not wearing masks you have to
be kidding me
oh they're pretending that the the
pandemic is over
it's like it doesn't exist anymore tom
denny says i've heard your mic cut in
and out the last couple videos it might
be the xlr cable connected to the
sm7 cheaper cables don't last very long
you know
i have a suspicion as to what it is i'm
gonna get really close to the mic
for a second okay tell me if this causes
the problem
testing one two one two testing one two
one two
did that cause the problem can anybody
tell me
oh looks like we have a delay oh no it
sounded fine
okay that's interesting yeah we had
two or three elements of static
yesterday during the show
and i just unplugged and replugged
everything
and i don't think we had the issue today
i don't think we had the issue today so
it might have just been a matter of
replugging
uh oh i've been muted for the last hour
oh my god i'm sorry
that's too bad okay danny thompson says
congrats on your latest chess match but
my word i played a better game of chess
at age 16 that i saw there i'm sure you
knew i would watch the game and you
played that way to make me feel good
about myself thanks
exactly danny exactly
wallace derekot says if the red mirage
scenario is likely would it be smart for
news networks to not have live coverage
of results on election night
so listen networks are going to have
live coverage of results on election
night the red mirage scenario is one
that a few data firms are
are raising the alarm about and the red
mirage would be
that on election day there is the mirage
of trump winning
but as vote by mail is counted because
that will be
disproportionately joe biden biden picks
up the win
in the later days and that would provide
time for donald trump to file lawsuits
and try to stop
the counting of absentee ballots it
could be a complete and total mess
so if the idea is prevent live coverage
of results
that ship has sailed there's no way that
people would agree not to do that
daraten says i know you're sober i can't
be for this thanks
okay that's brutal charlie says
trump's struggling to pronounce
hefseffahide
is the top trump sound bite and is
unlikely to be topped
yeah let me see if i can find that
that's one of my favorites
uh we are just moments from donald trump
looks like it's actually getting a
little sunny
trump let me see if i can find it it is
just a beautiful video
um
got it okay yeah this is the one that's
being referred to in super chat
i do like this one oh logic and
surface hide
yeah fefcephahide that i mean that's a
logical way to say it you know
it does make sense to me okay
elias feldstad says hey crazy thing is
we even have trump supporters here in
norway which i think is tragic
thank you for sane coverage of your
insane government thank you i appreciate
that
ruggiero says i heard this wacky theory
that the day before the first debate
biden will declare
he has tested positive for covet 19 and
will not participate
theory i mean how can someone predict
whether that
whether joe biden is going to test
positive now if the argument is he is
going to claim it
without actually having tested positive
very conspiratorial
let me say thank you to killa sim for
subscribing with twitch
prime and natto sun for subscribing with
prime it is september so if you're
watching on twitch and if you are of
course
we very much appreciate our twitch
supporters
twitch actually out doing facebook today
the last few streams
facebook has obliterated twitch in terms
of viewers
which is which is quite an insult quite
frankly to twitch
but today twitch is leading and it is
september
as donald trump donald trump coming out
clapping
uh you know what it actually doesn't
seem like down or trump it seems like
upper trump
i think i've uh i've misspoken there
dominic richardson says yeah good okay
but i actually you're so anytime you see
that you're supposed to pronounce it
like bernie it's
yeah good okay yeah good okay
super guy says can states count mail-in
votes early to speed up counting
yes yes on election day
but the answer is yes let's pay very
close attention to donald trump hitting
the
stairs in the meantime lee babcock
is new member number 13 today
jeremy wolf is number fourteen emily
art antonelle is number fifteen
trigvy smedsrud is number sixteen
shannon hunnaker is number 17
here is trump very very careful and uh
you know we don't want him to
suffer a fall and very carefully walking
up
the angle by the way that they choose
for this is just absurd
it's completely absurd we're keeping it
muted because of the music until he
speaks
lisa gallant is new member number 18.
michael maine is new member number 19.
adam
feyerty is new member number 20.
where is trump karen felton is new
member number 21
and nicholas page is new member number
22
tony hall new member 23. beautiful
our goal is only 25 so i do invite you
to go to join pacman.com and grab a
membership let's see what we've got
going on
[Music]
okay so donald trump we are dangerously
close
to donald trump speaking uh lance
smith liked my take on dr shiva from
massachusetts yeah that guy's out of his
mind
completely out of his mind ziltoid
the omniscient says what are the
realistic chance that by what's the
chance biden wins and harris takes over
due to deterioration
very low very very low
um donald trump identifying people in
the crowd i guess to point to
here we go buckle up folks
[Applause]
unclear if trump will mention
fefcephahide today
or convalescent plasma fatilities we'll
see
pennsylvania very much i'm thrilled to
be in
latrobe the home of the late great
my friend arnold palmer
what a great guy he was what a great guy
thank you very much 61 days from now
we're going to win the commonwealth of
pennsylvania
and we are going to win four more years
in the white house
[Applause]
[Music]
joe biden wants to surrender your jobs
to china you know that
so he's starting up with the slap and
elbow the slap and elbow that's his move
now
if you're doing nothing he wants to
surrender your nation
to the radical left wing mob he's trying
to change now you know he's saying
that's not working because
we're going up and he's dropping like a
rock in water
that's factually untrue just so people
know
and before the china virus this election
was over now i had to go back to work
and we've done a great job on it we
don't get the credit
the worst job in the world we made a lot
of governors look very good
but i will keep your jobs in america and
i'll bring
rioters looters violent extremists
anarchists we will bring them to justice
that's what we're doing right now
we have over 400 right now under arrest
he's a bad people over the last
three and a half years we've secured
america's borders
fixed our broken trade deals rebuilt the
united states military
obliterated the isis caliphate 100
not true secured american
energy independence and built
the single greatest economy in the
history of the world
and now we're going to do it again have
to do it again
got to do it again a lot of slapping
that podium huh
lectern i'm sorry it's happening you see
what's happening job numbers
retail sale numbers they're all at
records it's happening it's happening
very fast
it's actually happening in a super v not
a v it's a super v
that's a lot you see that and big
numbers are coming out and have come
out and uh just watch your set
or watch your newspaper read your
newspaper you're seeing numbers that
congressmen we haven't seen those
numbers ever before actually
we've never seen them and by the way we
have record stock markets
we have record everything you're going
to have
you're going to have an incredible
economic year next year
your stocks are going up your 401k
are through the roof
had a little pause today people wanted
to take some profits and probably
somebody said something stupid along the
way
right but uh the stock market's at
record levels think of it
in the hopefully rounding the turn on
the pandemic we're rounding that turn
and vaccines are coming along great you
know that
uh the job that they've done the doctors
everybody
else we're years ahead of schedule
anybody else as president
you wouldn't be talking about vaccines
for two or three years from now i'll
tell you right now
that i can tell you biden will never be
able
to protect your jobs or your family he
is a puppet of the socialists marxist
and the top hating so that's actually
dangerous
there's nothing socialistic or marxist
about biden anybody with even an ounce
of common sense
or intelligence would know that but he's
repeating it because it's working it's
actually resonating with some of his
most
cognitively compromised people you're
seeing it we have
thousands of people behind this hangar
thousands and we're trying to get them
in
and i'd love to get them in i mean it's
an airport let them go to the runways
okay
[Music]
let them in too many people we have i
mean literally there
we landed i actually thought that was
the crowd
you know we're doing the hanger thing
now because the arenas
can't do it because of the pandemic for
a while a little while
but in certain ways i like this better i
don't have to travel i get off the plane
i make a speech i get the hell out of
here right
it's better for me too to be perfectly
frank
naughties are great you remember the
last days before the campaign i
do a lot of them a day get off that
plane it was a little different plan it
was black and white instead of the blue
and white
blue but we had some time and uh that
was an important
that was an important day and that was
an important year 2016
but i will tell you the election that we
have coming up
is the single most important election
in the history of this country it well
maybe
i actually think i agree on that he had
a level of enthusiasm i mean even look
today
with all going on look at look at the
kind of crowds we have and
but we had record enthusiasm in 2016. by
the way was that the greatest evening
ever
november and now it's going to be
november 3rd and we'll keep it going and
we'll get it all like a tree you
move that tree it takes a little while
to plant your tax cuts
they're going to raise your taxes wait
you move the tree after you plant it i'm
interested
that's an interesting thing i've not
that's expensive to move big trees
besides me for saying this fake news
media which is back there
with their fake with their fake poles
the same as leisure we could just put it
all on tape
the fake poles the fake everything
the fake you know they're called
suppression poles
they're meant to make you depressed are
you depressed you don't look depressed
you know you'd think if the polls
falsely say trump is losing that his
supporters would say wow i've really got
to go vote i mean even the idea that
that would suppress
is is certainly questionable
i think we're way ahead of what we were
four years ago and there's far
more enthusiasm our base is bigger it's
stronger
and we've done the greatest job again if
we didn't get hit by the plague from
china this thing we wouldn't have even
between us i would have canceled mr
congressman
most of the rallies i wouldn't have
needed a rally
okay that's a little bit unfair but
that's okay that's what china has done
to our nation they've screwed us for a
long time on
a lot of different ways never has
anybody ripped off our nation like
china and i've taken in billions and
billions of dollars we never
we never took in 10 cents from china
and i gave 28 billion right 28 billion
to the farmers because they were
targeted unfairly what does that mean
even
what does that even mean we didn't take
10 cents from china they're continually
buying our debt i mean it just seems
like a meaningless vapid statement
in this wonderful pennsylvania town i
know we have a lot of boilermakers over
there
we've got a lot of boilermakers i'll be
talking about them
look at those guys nobody going to mess
with them i'll tell you we're going to
be talking about them in a minute but
for the entire summer biden was silent
as far left rioters viciously attacked
law enforcement and democrat-run cities
all
of course that's not true biden has
denounced violence multiple times and
trump
continues to pretend that that hasn't
happened it's chanting death to america
this is what we have
death to america i actually didn't see
the death to america
protests i'd be interested in seeing
that i didn't see it though in wisconsin
it ended
took a while for the governor you know
they have to ask us in
it's like otherwise uh we have to do
something much bigger and it's totally
unnecessary the national guard
is fantastic i went to see him two days
ago biden went there today there was
nobody there
there was nobody there he was a little
late i was going to say hey listen we
ended that problem
but we could end it in portland wise
guys in portland anarchists
they're agitators they're looters i'll
tell you we could end it in portland
in a half an hour
and and would anybody get hurt if you
ended it in a half hour i wonder
we're coming in congressman we were
going in the next day we're all set
i was actually disappointed to be honest
they ended it in seattle they took over
20
of the city do you believe this and the
mayor said no it's going to be a summer
of love
these people are crazy
this is none of this is true i hope you
guys know that none of this is true
very quickly and now what we're doing
and if it were true trump's president
it's happening under his watch it has
nothing to do with biden doing where
they allow crime to run rampant
and we put a 10-year prison sentence on
anybody that knocks down a
statue
i didn't cheering for that
i took out an old ordinance a very old
one because today in congress you don't
get things like that today they think
that
you should just have no cash bail you
know they do the no cash bail
you kill somebody there's no bail don't
worry about it go out
but i took out an old ordinance i gave a
new executive order
says 10 years in prison and
amazingly amazingly
that was like three and a half months
ago and they were having a big march on
washington
march elsewhere and amazingly that was
the end of the statues coming down
yeah what actually happened is it just
sort of ran its course it's not like
people are indefinitely going to be
trying to pull down statues not to
mention some of the most
problematic ones city councils voted to
remove them i mean it's all like it's
this weird revisionist history
constantly
or lack of understanding but the rioters
that
want biden to win they want him to win
because their agenda
isn't a agenda it's what they want i can
assure you that the rioters
aren't voting for biden the very few
people that are rioting
if they're voting at all would would
argue by and large that
both trump and biden are parts of the
same problem
left district attorney in portland mike
schmidt his name is
has released hundreds of rioters and
announced that anyone arrested
for interfering with police officers
disorderly conduct
criminal trespass rioting and other
offenses will not be prosecuted
under any circumstance
oh it's worse it's worse you have
somebody in philadelphia who's worse
right
yeah who tell us whereas in his
manifesto with bernie
sanders that's what it is biden agreed
to all these things you know
you notice now no no i never said about
frackie and i never said
if you don't do fracking in pennsylvania
900 000 jobs and your energy bills will
triple other
joe biden said we've got to get off
fracking good that's great
in the manifesto plus he said many times
you know we put on the clip yesterday
where he no fracking no this know that i
mean no guns how about guns no guns no
second amendment
yeah now that is dangerous and remember
that
so record guns were sold under obama why
because you had the dangerous fear
mongering of he's going to take the guns
you'd better buy a whole bunch of them
and that's exactly what they're talking
get rid of the second amendment what are
you talking about
drip that this was possible crazy
burning you know crazy burning
you know i had a lot of his voters came
to come to me four years ago
a big percentage you know why because i
agree with him and he agrees with with
me on one thing
trade the trade because he knew that
other countries are ripping us off and
so did i nobody else got it
especially biden never got it he never
got it
still doesn't get it now he really gets
nothing i'll tell you
he didn't get it in prime time now he
really doesn't get it
but it's okay for them there's more
biden dementia stuff
like portland which is a disaster and
again
we could clean it up we just go right
through it
5 000 10 000 right through it these guys
are tough they're smart and they love
our country they love our country
we'll clean it up in one half hour trump
alluding to violence by federal troops
he would send in
[Music]
did you see this radical left mayor
wheeler his name is
the radical left mayor they chased him
mike
they chased him out of his home last
night
and all he does is be nice to them
because they don't understand nice
they only understand one thing strength
that's the only thing they ended they
don't understand nice
they chased him out of his home
unbelievable
biden's plan is to appease the domestic
terrorists and my plan is to arrest them
and prosecute them
oh okay oh all right there won't be
prosecution if biden's president okay
yeah
defend law-abiding citizens that's why
the rioters
are voting for biden and the law
enforcement
people you know we have it from
everybody we just got the sheriffs in
florida all of them all of them we got
ohio we got texas we got
north carolina we got south carolina we
got everybody
i don't know if there's anybody and i
see rick perry right there
rick perry what are you doing here rick
rick perry one of the greats
what the hell is rick perry randomly in
the audience
this election is about safety and this
election is about jobs
today i'm delighted to accept a very
very special endorsement from people i
like
sort of grew up with these people i
don't know what it is the relationship
we have with all of us
with all of us but i'm endorsing i'm
getting an endorsement tonight from some
very very he's industrial people they
work hard they're endorsing they do
great
we really put them back to work because
this state was in trouble in last year
you had the single greatest
year economic year in the history
of your whole operation
right somebody
this has been your greatest this has
been
prior to the plague coming in it's been
the commonwealth's greatest
can we ever call the commonwealth of
state you have two places
you always have to say well wait a
minute is this one a commonwealth two
places you know what the other place is
name it huh what's he talking about how
did you know that congressman
he seems to be having a medical incident
right now it's commonwealth it's a great
commonwealth it's a great place
and the boilermakers local union
what the hell is going on right now it's
local 154 of the boilermakers they
chartered in pittsburgh
125 years ago none of you are around to
see it
and it now represents members in
pennsylvania
ohio and west virginia and i want to
thank
john hughes and the boilermakers here
today
it's a great honor to have you let me
who's john where the hell is john
stand up john
[Music]
yeah he seems to be having a real issue
here we appreciate it
do you know why john is the head you
know why because look he's got the worst
location
i say where's john i'm looking in the
front row he said put up your hand john
look at that guy he's good
you've got my vote john hey this is
really convincing if you're unsure who
to vote for you might see this and be
like wow i've really got to vote
to allow me to move to another country
great indoors
that's a great endorsement
joe biden spent the last 47 years
shipping pennsylvania jobs to china and
foreign nations
and i've spent the last four years
bringing them back home and we're
bringing them back home
bringing a lot of things back home
i ended the last administration's
eight-year
pure war on pennsylvania oil
and coal and fracking the national
if you look at the natural gas what
they've done to this
what they were doing to this day it was
sort of easy i just opened it up and i
said do it
and the investment put into pennsylvania
the investment put into the commonwealth
of pennsylvania has been
record-setting but again you had the
greatest year
you've ever had last year prior to the
virus you're going to be set now with
what we're doing
i believe that this next quarter which
will be announced
interestingly just prior to the election
so i'm putting myself on the line but i
know what's going to happen the numbers
are going to be great
and next year is going to be one of the
greatest years not only for people
that's the garbage math i've been
telling you guys about which is that the
q3 numbers will be announced on october
30th and obviously they're going to be a
big rise
from q2 because q2 was the worst porter
on record and trump will claim victory
joe hayden we have a new one joe hayden
we call him joe hayden i have all of
them what do you like better
what do you like better we got a number
let's do a little poll can we do a poll
i saved myself so much money
you know i saved myself so much money we
do these polls with thousands
and those people are coming in from the
back are they not
yes they're coming in i'm telling you
wouldn't have believed it
i'm landing i wasn't waving at you i was
waving at them there's more
but i do these polls right and
it's like a perfect poll you know do you
ever see the companies you give them a
million bucks and they
do a poll like 78 people were polled no
you got thousands of people
so tell me what's your feeling
first of all in the name what's it you
like
magga make america great again yes
huh oh you are the one you are a man i
made you famous today
you said the nicest things about me
thank you did you see him on television
today
what is happening i think you're great
i think you're great thank you now he
called me a great christian and a great
christian leader
you'd have to be an idiot to believe
that
[Music]
thank you but he did say i wasn't
perfect
but that's okay i said thank you anyway
right no that was really great
that was really great but
if you look at it the things they've
done
we're going to go through a couple of
different polls as we go along because i
love
the people saying do this or do that but
one of the things i got you out of is
this thing
sounds so good but it's so bad it's a
rip-off of our country
the so-called paris climate accord it's
a disaster a death sentence
it's a death sentence for your energy
jobs i took it out
i withdrew from that calamity biden
pledged to reinstate it it's going to
cost you billions and billions of
dollars
you know what it really is it's a way of
really taking advantage how much are
trump's tariffs costing us right now
i visited the shell petrochemical plant
in beaver county
anybody ever hear a beaver council
the largest investment in your state's
history
all made possible by our pro-energy
policies
biden would wipe out that entire
industry killing the jobs of more than
600
000 pennsylvania workers it's probably
nine hundred and forty thousand they say
think of that also prices and everything
else
now biden today came out and said no no
fracking's okay it's okay you just see
that fracking's okay
because he was getting killed and now he
came out in favor of law enforcement
look at all these handsome cops here
this is really a rorschach test it's
like an ink blot this is like a pollock
uh painting right i mean this is bizarre
he's totally against at his speech and
at the dnc
where we got much higher numbers than
they did but you know they put out that
they did
they'll say anything we got much higher
by millions and millions of people
not true wait did we have a great
convention
here's my guy
good job you did but we had a great
convention and it's been uh really
terrific you know
i made a speech at mount rushmore and
since that speech our numbers have been
up up this has to be off script right i
mean
i've never actually seen it this bad it
does seem i was wrong about downer trump
it's very much upper trump
sense that we've done such a good job
with the ventilators all of the things
you know you've heard it a thousand
times
and we have to get back and i made a
speech
in really a great place south dakota but
it was
mount rushmore you know they want to
blow it up you know they want to take
off now right
no if you would see how beautiful
if you would see how beautiful this is
it was like this perfect evening
who who wants to blow up mount rushmore
biden this is this is idiocy
majestic heroes of our country right
heroes of our country
[Applause]
and they want to blow up mount rushmore
but how about this one the democrats
yesterday came out with a plan did you
see it
now they're the d.c democrats they want
to change the name of the washington
monument perhaps take it down
this is actually tragic it's tragic that
this is the president of the united
states there's no
there's really no other words for it you
could forget about ever hearing that
name again abraham lincoln you could
forget about it
they want to take down all statues all
monuments in washington
we have some of your greatest people
right here let me not even talk to the
congressman the heck with the
congressman the boilermakers
how do you like how do you like the idea
of taking down our statues to our
great george washington thomas jefferson
abraham lincoln
andrew jackson all of them i don't think
the boilermakers
you'll ring you'll do a ring around
washington right along with
if this guy gets another four years we
all really are going to need to do some
self
some examination of this country i i
just i don't know how how else to say it
they tried to take down they tried to
take down
christopher columbus statue in new york
you saw what happened right these
italians formed a little circle they say
come on
italians the agitators decided to leave
let's get out of here darling
they protected christopher columbus the
italians no the italians aren't big on
taking down christopher columbus you
take down those statues you can forget
about the italian vote do we agree
but they protected it when asked in a
debate
if there would be any place for fossil
fuels including coal
and fracking and natural gas and so many
things that really fire up these big
plants where many of you work and
they produce you know just millions and
millions of jobs throughout our country
biden said no we would absolutely not
allow anything like that we would make
sure it's totally eliminated
it's not even clear what trump is
asserting it's certainly untrue
whatever it is but it's not even clear
what the assertion he's making is
and there's been about 100 or 200
assertions made so far we had crowds
that were unbelievable on the highways
it you can't get in but the highways
it's like
incredible you could sell your ticket
tonight for a lot of money go to ebay
even as a used ticket you could probably
sell right but you go down the highways
and you see and i was thinking in texas
i'm making a speech in front of
obviously people that like oil
they like god and you know what else
they like they like their second
amendment right
so so think about it
so whether it's pennsylvania or texas or
oklahoma or north dakota or any any
place
you take a look at this right and no oil
no guns no god i don't think
george washington running with abraham
lincoln as his vp will pick abraham
lincoln as vp is going to win in texas
or in pennsylvania or anyplace else with
those three things
eliminated that's what they want to do
they want to take away your second
amendment if i weren't president
you would either have an obliterated
second amendment or it would be gone
and remember that's what they said
before obama when obama took office and
more guns than ever
were sold during barack obama's
presidency there were more guns than
ever floating around
it's the same thing it's the same lie
he put vado in charge of guns vado's in
charge he wants to get rid of everything
beto that's a beauty remember he said i
was born for this
anybody that says they're born for this
remember better he was on the cover of a
magazine i won't mention the magazine
they're back there it's a total phony
magazine
but he was on the cover yeah it's fake
paper they claim it's paper it's not
even paper
to run for presser he was born for it i
was born
anybody that gets that character that
was when he was doing well
carried away trump said i am the only
person who can fix the problems that the
u.s is dealing with trump said only i
can
fix it he says beto got carried away and
he got put in charge of guns
so i guess biden pretty soon is going to
be coming out saying no no i never said
that
check out all of the statement he's made
on everything
and now he's going the opposite way but
he's agreed to the manifesto entirely
so maybe he'll do that and then he
figures later on he'll go but
everything he said is right because he
has no control
over what's happening the radical left
has captured the party
they even elected a person
that nobody ever heard of a senator it's
been a while
against a young good-looking kennedy
by 10 points yeah ed markey
what what what's wrong with that you
know why because he wasn't
a radical left he was like a semi-normal
person just slightly left
oh my god but think of it this is what's
happened and this is really what's
happened
if you're not a radical marquee is now a
radical
guns meaning fossil fuels they want wind
wind you know to make the windmill which
are made mostly in china
and in germany by the way to make it so
much emission
is let out that it's more than you can
ever save it's just the craziest thing
that's very much untrue i'm a big i am
truly an environmentalist
but you have to understand when we do
things
and they don't and we clean and it's
very expensive to do that and they don't
and we have this massive planet china
india russia germany all these places
it's fuming up
and we're doing germany's fuming up
they have to do it also otherwise it
just doesn't work
the way it's supposed to
wow how insightful huh
they want to ban straws has anybody ever
tried those paper straws they're not
working
right they want to ban straws i said
well
you know i've had how soon until he goes
into toilets that you have to flush 15
times he's getting in that direction
right
these friend of mine owns wendy's i'll
give it a plug right burger king
so they want to ban straws they said oh
really what about the carton
what about the plate what about the
knives and the spoons that are plastic
oh they're okay but the straws we gotta
ban
has anybody ever tried seriously the new
sort's made out of paper right
it disintegrates as you're drinking if
you have a nice tie like this tie
this would have no chance by the time
you get finished the straw is totally
disintegrated
does anybody walk around with a plastic
straw because it's not bad you know you
whip it out boom boom
you never had to do that when asked
whether he would
be willing to destroy the jobs whip it
out boom boom
you never had to do that when asked
whether he would
be willing to destroy the jobs of
hundreds of thousands of blue-collar
workers
to push his anti-energy agenda you know
what the answer is right
it's the green new deal right the screen
indeed this was made by
this was made up sounds good this was
made up by people that don't get it
either that or people that just don't
like our country very much
but biden replied yes the first thing
people want to do who don't like our
country
is keep it cleaner that that's really
somebody who hates america i've never
seen a man that liked their mascot
look i'm all for it we have a big
weekend distance on the weekend and all
of that stuff and
wear your mask when you close together
in particular and wash your hands all
those things we have labor day
weekend coming up but did you ever see a
man that likes a mask as much as him
and then he makes a speech and he always
has it not always but a lot of times he
has it hanging down
because you know what it gives him a
feeling of security if i were a
psychiatrist
right no i'd say substantive huh i'd say
this guy's got some big issues
[Applause]
hang in there congressman give me your
mask i want to have it hanging from my
i don't want to touch your damn mask
mike i'll never touch your man
[Applause]
no but the new one is you this is this
is really depressing
sir would you like to go over to walter
reed it's incredible by the way
the job they do on people that have been
just really hurt are heroes
and the job they do is incredible but
sir would you like to go over and do a
physical uh oh you have some time oh no
time some deal not this again china i
decided not to see china
because they didn't like the way they
were doing business okay is he gonna
come clean about why he went
doctor white house doctor highly
respected
sean sean connelly sir would you like to
go over and do your physical or do a
piece of it or finish it or whatever it
was but do a physic
i said i don't know i'm not in love with
the idea well let's
if you do it we don't have to do it so
okay let's go come on so we went
way one and we're driving now you have
to understand there are like
you know 100 cars you see what happens
here it's like the plane times
50. so the cars are driving all over
about a 20-minute drive this is
interesting we get to the hospital i get
out
i was there probably for an hour and a
half two hours
and then yesterday i read that i had
strokes wrong
he denied having strokes without anyone
asserting it remember that that's weird
what was asserted is that pence was
warned he may have to be anesthetized
beyond standby and trump comes out and
said i didn't have any strokes it's like
who said strokes
i don't know what a mini stroke is but
it's not good
and there could be a day and donald
admit i said hey it happens to all of us
right
except these young ones it's never going
to happen to them they're not looking at
that but you know what happens
but nothing happens so i went in i did
that part of the physical the end result
was he's very healthy
they're very unhappy it would be great
to hear what he did during that hour and
a half
what you don't remember is when this
took place it was a long time ago they
just started up
because we wanted they want to try and
get me to be in
biden's physical level you know they
viewed me as being somebody that's you
know
i go around hey last week
this week texas north carolina
florida south carolina back to
washington
let's go here let's go there let's go
everywhere meetings all the time
i think i've answered more questions
from these maniacs than any president
in history
and mean questions you know i watch
biden
[Music]
and mean questions you know i watched
biden yesterday
so he hasn't answered questions in what
two months or something
and yesterday he took a couple and they
were set ups like i've never seen
one young woman who i think is there one
young woman
is smiling hi hi
hi hi i'd just like to ask you i'm sorry
to bother you with this question
it's the most incredible
so the doctor wrote a letter saying no
this uh
rumor is wrong and i don't like you know
rumors like that
and by the way if it were a fact it's
fine it should i think it's an important
thing but
if it's not true my wife was
like she came to me she said i think i
would have known that i said yeah i
think they would have known her too
because they drove back with me you know
the press follows me
can anybody explain what's going on then
they followed me
and then we go in we go out but if you
remember last time
i go in i spend a little time physical
like we all have hopefully you have them
good thing to have i guess as long as
they give you a good answer if they give
you a bad answer don't bother
there's a little too much time being
spent on this for this to be nothing but
i go in
i come out a couple of hours later i
guess whatever it is short time later
i get into the car the press sees me get
into the guys he was there for two hours
for a part of his physical why is that
so weird
from my wife the first lady who's very
popular do we like our first one
you're very popular great person great
woman
she said darling are you okay
i go why do you ask she said they're
reporting that you had a heart attack
i don't think that was reported either
which is about what six cars in front of
the press
because they have a big car a lot of
them and we try and
give them as little room as possible
make it uncomfortable
but they're right behind me so they know
i got in
and cnn reported that i had a heart
attack that was the same visit
i don't think that's true at all
no it's unbelievable cnn reported i had
a heart attack so my wife was concerned
i said no
not that i know of and if i did i think
i'd be back there no i'm
i'll be home in 15 minutes darling thank
you for caring
i'm sure he calls her darling huh
she sounded relieved that's good when
your wife sounds relieved
but she said i wonder how that happened
why did they do that because they're
fake news
so i go in and that rumor lasted for a
little while like
a day or two it lasted for a little
while no matter what i did you know i
walk i'm
in the same motorcade i go in and i go
out
they know i'm in the motorcade i
actually have to report it but i'm in
the motorcade
and they said i had to cut one of them
said it was a massive heart attack think
of it
i don't know again it could happen
someday okay and when it does
i hope things work out
but they knew i'm in the motorcade and
yet they reported it anyway because
they're fake news
now for the same visit that was the same
you know that was the stupidest thing
from now on when i go for a physical or
something or go to the hospital
announce it because this was a quick
thing
the doctor he got me a lot of trouble
he's a great doctor two hours
no more surprise visits to the hospital
where we do a little work because we
have some time
remember previously they said it wasn't
a surprise now he's saying yeah yeah
yeah no it was a surprise they said no
more surprises
times as a third great reporter writes a
book
and he said the vice president was
prepared
to take over the reigns because they
thought the president was going to go i
guess under anesthesia do they still
call it
in the old days they called it
anesthesia it's essentially the same
thing
it's the same as what i want to get into
a situation like where biden
used record player remember that
you go home you turn on your record
player what
but the anesthesia and
i said how could that be so remember
just the same visit same visit
they said heart attack a long time all
of a sudden out of this book
and he said suffered mini strokes
now they get that wasn't claimed in the
book it's not
claimed in the book but they still go
with it they go with it
and they know i'm in the group with them
coming back and if you i don't know much
about a mini stroke
but i assume mr congressman if you have
a mini stroke you're not heading back to
the white house right
at least you'll spend a couple of nights
at that great hospital right
so anyway these are really dangerous
people they are so
bad for our country if we know i'm
seeing most of the danger coming from
this guy being president
they're just a bunch of phony people not
all of them you have some very good ones
like about 10 no you have some very good
ones you have some great journalists but
it's really they know it's phony stuff
they're doing anything they can to get
this sleepy guy into the white house and
i just don't think
the public is going to fall for it
[Applause]
i don't think the public is going to
fall for it you know in his best days 25
30 years ago he was weak
he was weak as a senator he was weak he
was not known as being one of the smart
ones and now it's not exactly
prime time i can tell you that
i just want to announce tonight because
we're joined with some very very special
warriors
and dan muser dan thank you very much
great job you're doing dan
congressman he's a congressman who have
really been warriors for me i really
have been
thank you very much dan fred keller fred
thank you great job brett
[Applause]
the great john joyce great
great thank you john
[Applause]
melton guy reshenthaler do you know
digression russian thawler i like how
they spelled that in the closed captions
what are you doing over there what
happened you don't get along with these
guys huh
oh okay that's good now i understand
that's good
glenn thompson
great job great job is he one of the
thompson twins
and a real good friend of mine right
from the beginning right mike you know
we were
in pennsylvania and a friend of ours a
congressman long term
right from kentucky no from actually
tennessee
came up to us i was getting ready to
make a speech
and tennessee has very early voting
remember what he said
this was four years ago he said i don't
know what's happening in pennsylvania
i don't know what's happening in the
rest of the country but if what's going
on in the rest of the country
is like what's going on in tennessee he
said they're coming from
the hills the roadsides the rivers he
said they're coming
they should be heading for the hills
vote they're great americans but they
never wanted to vote for the people that
they would see
he said they're miles long they've got
trump here
trump pats trump pins right
tennessee
congressman duncan right remember that
mike
that was the first time i mean they said
they've never seen anything like it
tennessee has been incredible by the way
but
so mike and i listened and we said i
wonder
what that's all about but it is true
people that weren't really political
people
they're coming in and you know i've said
before trump is part of the problem but
the fact that there will be 60 million
people who voted for
him even if he loses is a really big
problem as well
just imagine what kind of a person you
have to be to see this and to think this
is someone fit to serve
right that so there will be 60 million
of those
people in the country in january no
matter who's president
think about that
another great friend of mine is a tough
cookie and
a great congressman but he unfortunately
he's a former
uh because he's just uh i don't know
he's just a special guy
and really has a big beautiful heart lou
barletta
lou thank you you look good luke
why don't you run again
and a man who's tough you know there's
this guy
you ever hear of a guy named conor lamb
he's like a lamb
[Applause]
so we heard you know because he's in
sort of a trumpy area right and we heard
that he's going to be for trump but he's
going to be fighting for trump
and you know i sort of i saw some of his
commercials i thought he was a
republican right
except when he got to washington he
voted with pelosi a hundred percent of
the time
politically crazy nancy he voted with
crazy nancy
and so we thought this is conor lamb guy
he even voted to impeach your president
over nothing
zero
and that's very personal when they do
that that's personal
so and and i have to say congressman
196 to nothing they stuck with us and so
did the senate other than romney you can
have romney i'll tell you
romney couldn't be elected dog catcher
in utah right now
although he gave me romney would easily
win re-election to the senate 52 and a
half to a half
that was romney what a beard remember he
was walking with the black lives matter
saying yes i'm a member of black lives
matter everyone's saying that's nice
wonderful
remember he didn't say anything about
membership
but we uh we did a great job we had a
great uh we had it was an amazing thing
but this conor lamb was out there
fighting it and he shouldn't have done
that and we have somebody that
blows him away he's more of a hero
he's tougher he's stronger he's smarter
he's better looking not that that
matters
you know under the metoo generation i
don't talk about looks anymore
looks don't matter doesn't make any
difference i don't talk about looks me
too
me too generation but i'll tell you this
man is something special
he's a real hero a real tough guy and
he'll never let you down
sean parnell oh
carnell's a lunatic
just remember that conor lamb and i
remember because he's like a lamb he's
like a little lamb
that's an insane usually isn't it a lot
of weak people
we like strong people don't we we like
that
we need strong people right now we have
somebody else in the audience who
served as my secretary of energy and he
was incredible
he was the governor of texas for what 12
years i think rick right 12. why is rick
perry there tell me 14
14 years he was and he was an incredible
governor and he was an incredible
secretary and he's been an
incredible friend
i would rap rick perry everybody
there was nobody that got into the race
tougher than rick what he said about me
i'll never repeat again
even my own family didn't like me when
he got finished
and when he decided that i would be the
one he got out
and there's nobody that said better
things about me
but you're great rick and you did a
fantastic job every every place you've
been you've been great thank you very
much
rick perry thank you i would i would cut
it hey rick how are we doing in texas
terribly ah
we had a poll today in georgia you know
they say george is going to be close
well this was a poll that hates trump
and we're up seven
that was the same thing happened last
time the poll had right
you know they used the words in play
george is in play they say
george is in play well we're up seven
and this is a poll that truly hates us
okay
imagine bragging about the fact that a
republican is going to win georgia
and then it was eight o'clock the polls
closed and they only announced if you're
way ahead
so they say the polls have closed in the
great state of texas donald trump
has won the great state of texas
and i kept hearing it was in play they
said utah
the home of our worst i don't remember
anybody saying
texas was in play for hillary do any of
you guys remember anybody saying texas
was in play for hillary
i didn't want to get them confused by
them
but they say utah same thing remember
that four years ago we hit the guy with
a shaved head what was his name rick
what what a what a loser that was you
know
that's right a mcmuffin i think
something like that
and he was going to win utah and i
wanted by many many many points it was
called immediately
so these are people that are just not
good in fact hillary even beat this guy
hillary hillary came in second in utah
in less than four years we've achieved
more than anyone thought possible we
passed massive tax cuts for hard-working
families so now i guess he's getting
back on script it's time to end it
nations than any administration in the
history of our country
i saved the u.s auto industry by
withdrawing from the last
administration's
job-killing catastrophe known as the
trans-pacific partnership it would have
been a catastrophe
not only for autos by the way for
everything else too
to protect our workers i imposed stiff
tariffs on foreign
aluminum and foreign steel that kept you
guys very busy
they were dumping all over the place is
that right they were dumping
remember it was bad steel to lose dirt
steel
this week my administration reached a
breakthrough agreement to stop
additional steel imports from brazil and
from mexico
for the rest of the year despite the
usmca sometimes
they get a little carried away and we
have to do a little tariff action on
them
so we stopped that we're reversing
decades of the biden betrayals that
decimated pennsylvania jobs you know
that
this state lost listen to this one in
three
manufacturing jobs after the twin
disasters of nafta
and china's entrance into the world
trade organization one of the worst
things that happened when china came in
you know they were flatlined for many
years then they came into this crazy
deal
they're considered a developing nation
you see i've been sort of protesting
that like
but they're considering china as a
developing nation you get all sorts of
things that you would never get
advantages over the united states well
we have very strongly protested that
they're not a developing nation they're
a very powerful developed nation
and you know what they got to pay what
everyone else has to pay
right earlier this year i kept my
promise
to the commonwealth of pennsylvania when
we ended the nafta nightmare and signed
the brand new u.s
mexico candidate does anybody know why
he keeps slapping the side of the
lectern with his right hand
it'll never happen and i had great help
from these gentlemen right here
i took the toughest ever action to stand
up to china's
pillaging plundering and rampant theft
of pennsylvania and many other places
jobs
that's all throughout the world by the
way but our states
have been just pillaged by china and
others
joe biden's agenda is made in china my
agenda is made
in america
[Applause]
after years and years of rebuilding
other countries we are finally
rebuilding our country it's called
america first
america first that's enough
and we're bringing our soldiers back
home you see what's going on
after 19 years in afghanistan
far away places to bring hope to our
inner cities i created opportunity zones
tim scott
great senator from south carolina worked
on it with me
past criminal justice reform delivered
permanent funding
for historically black colleges and
universities that
obama would never do and before the
china virus we achieved the lowest
african-american
hispanic american asian-american
unemployment rates
ever recorded by far
and they're now heading back in that
direction quickly
democrat politicians have failed the
black community for decades they failed
the
asian community the hispanic community
they failed women
the numbers on women's unemployment
were the best in 61 years biden spent
the last 47 years
betraying the american people
he was always for things that you
wouldn't want and now he's changing no i
never said that i never said that
i've spent the last four years keeping
my promises
and delivering for the african-american
community and for all communities is he
going to do the lincoln line this
is yet to come
perhaps in no area have our opponents
more thoroughly portrayed working
families of all backgrounds than on the
subject of immigration you know we've
been fighting for that
under my administration we achieved the
most secure border in american history
we ended catch and release stop the
asylum for
and we've deported 20 000 gang members
and we get them out and we get them out
there
that number is hard to believe i i'd
like to see more data on that
ice and border patrol they don't like
ice because ice
is they're tough you got to be tough in
that job by the way
anybody up here like to work in ice i
don't think so let's see you could
you could probably be okay but you'd
rather do what you're doing right
i agree with you these are tough guys
they have to be tough
these are bad bad gang members
i mean you look at ms-13 you look at
what's happened with ms-13 you look at
but we get them the hell out sometimes
we have to put them in prison because we
don't even want to take a chance and can
come back in after what they've done we
built 300 miles of border wall
and we're adding 10 new miles every
single one
every week and the wall will be finished
very soon and by the way
no it won't but mexico will be paying
for the wall and i say it respectfully
to mexico but they will be paying for
the water there is no
chance in hell mexico pays for the wall
which is not being built
it is very well the president of mexico
right now they have 27
000 mexican soldiers on our border
guarding
us from people coming in illegally
[Music]
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
united states military
and launched the first new branch of the
united states armed forces in nearly
75 years since the air force and that's
called
the space force
right sean pretty good
i'm going to send mike into space you
want to go into space but
our great congressman okay but think of
that
you know we created a new branch of the
united states
that alone if you had that that alone
but then you add judges all the other
things we pass va
choice and va accountability remember va
choices the 2014
obama bill donald trump did not pass it
he made some tweaks but that is an obama
accomplishment
barack obama you might remember
get better quickly
and accountability we keep people
accountable for the way they treat
our veterans and if they don't treat
them well we say sorry
you're fired get out well we couldn't
fire anybody
we had sadists we had thieves we had
some very bad people
and they're all gone thank you i love
you too thank you
thank you such friendly voices right
beautiful
only in pennsylvania right thank you
i went through from the last
administration's disastrous
iran nuclear deal think of this obama
paid 150 billion for a short-term deal
he gave 1.8 billion in cash you ever see
a million dollars like at a casino floor
or something
in hundred dollar bills it's a lot it's
like the size of this right
now think 1.8 billion how did you guys
allow that to happen
huh they said we all voted against it i
kept my promise
recognized the true capital of israel
it's a sign it's time to rap
you never know nowadays right
and i opened the u.s embassy in
jerusalem
jerusalem
i recognized israeli sovereignty over
the golan heights they've been trying to
get that done for 52 years i got it done
immediately
and by the way as far as the capital
of israel jerusalem they've been talking
about many many presidents they all
promised it nobody did it i did it
we get things done a lot of people
didn't do it because it's a terrible
idea
and we just did something that is
incredible
even the new york times gave it good
reviews again not good reviews beyond
good reviews
tom friedman gave it phenomenal reviews
you believe that
and that's we achieved the first
breakthrough
in middle east peace in decades
a deal with israel right
and the uae
to deal with israel and the uae and
that's going to lead and i will tell you
we have representatives over right now
and other people are saying we we want
to get in that
you'll have peace in the middle east but
we want to get the hell out let's get
them all back
let's get them all back don't forget
we're energy independent
there used to be a reason now we do have
all those
calls all over the place but and we have
some very good partnerships over there
in all fairness we have some countries
that have treated us very well and we're
going to take care of those countries
but we are energy independent for the
first time and that's a very good
feeling
and our military has never been stronger
than it is now it's new and it's
beautiful
and i told you we took over 100
of the isis caliphate in iraq and syria
and we killed the founder and leader of
isis al baghdadi
and separately we killed the world's
number one terrorist number one
terrorist for decades
how are you going to pronounce it kasum
salamani
it's a big step for the middle east we
kept america
out of wars remember they always said oh
this trump
he's radical he's really i mean he's off
the
he's too radical he'll get us in wars
i kept you out of wars what happened
with north korea look
i get along with kim jong-un he just
bragged about all the places he bombed
if i get along with russia is that a
good thing or a bad thing i think it's a
good thing
these maniacs anytime they always talk
about russia they never talk about china
you know it's very interesting
it's always russia i heard it starting
again they said
somebody spoke to russia two years ago
russia russia russia
this total maniac shifty shift he's a
total baby
so no it's always do you ever notice
i can't even listen but when i hear
russia i just turn it off it's crazy
but you know getting along with
countries is actually a good thing can
we explain that
it's a good thing not a bad thing oh
it's a very good thing
but remember i was the one that was
going to be leading you into war in the
first week he'll be in war he's a
radical kind of a personality i'm really
not i like that piece
but if we ever do get into war we will
knock the hell out of them
that's like a real base applause line
among a crowd like this
the tide they don't fight to win we
fight to win
but you look at what's happening uh
we're they're all coming back home i
even reduced in germany because germany
they're an ally but you know
they took advantage of us very badly on
trade and very badly with our military
so we removed a lot of soldiers out of
germany they're not happy they said this
is going to hurt our economy well it's
good for our economy okay
they thought it was going to hurt the
german economy well
they don't treat us right they don't pay
their bills they're delinquent
you know what delinquent is they
delinquent they don't pay their bills
we protect them they don't pay their
bills we got to do something and they
and they treat us horribly on trade
through the european union which
basically they run
together we've been rapidly fixing a
half a century of disasters and biden
was there for every one of them
biden's responsible for everything bad
that's happened
in the last 50 years anywhere in the
world
the korean deal was so bad it was so bad
this was a deal that was going to
produce in south korea
done by crooked hillary clinton this was
a deal
that was going to produce 250
000 jobs she said
this will be 250 000 and she was right
for south korea produced 215 000 for us
we got nothing we got now we got losses
we got nothing it was a terrible deal i
renegotiated now it's a good deal
and they also gave and want to give mass
amnesty for illegal aliens biden
supported cutting social security
i'm actually surprised how long he's
been going and it's just it's just
all over the place there's no rhyme or
reason to any of this he opposed the
killing of solomonia when i did that he
said that's a terrible thing
that's a terrible thing everybody in the
middle east they couldn't believe it
how long has it been celebrated some of
them quite quietly i must add
he oversaw the rise of isis wow and he
cheered the rise of
china as a positive development for
america and the entire world remember
that
now he's trying to say well i could be
tough in china too no he can't
china owns him china owns sleepy joe
he's not going to be tough in china and
he said all these wonderful things
and then all of a sudden his poll
numbers started going down
how about law enforcement he's like so
bad
in his entire convention they didn't
even mention and by the way
something else they did that i think is
terrible really terrible
the words under god right
right this is a lie called the pledge of
allegiance
under god he left those two words out
twice at their caucus which is
part of their convention but that's
where they're coming from
he's trying to say oh well we didn't do
this and then we gave it so the schedule
was for trump to be back
on the plane departing at 8 35 which is
in 20 minutes
so maybe it was scheduled to be this
long i don't know but uh it
it does have to start winding down if
they're going to get the plane off
20 minutes from now okay you sign it
and send it in and then you have to
follow it
and if on election day or early voting
that is not tabulated and counted
you go vote and then if for some reason
after that it shouldn't take that long
it comes in they're not going to be able
to tabulate it because you will have
voted
so he's now encouraging people to vote
twice again which is against the law
they're going to beat us
is by doing that kind of stuff i'm
trying to be nice
i'm trying to be nice they want to send
out congressmen
80 million ballots now there have been
many races over
the last year where they've done this
and they've been a disaster
you look at new york they had a con
congressional
race not a very good congresswoman
very untalented i know her well i lived
in new york she's
not got much going they have no idea
what the vote is
i think 20 of the ballots were
missing and then they declared her the
winner and the other guy said what about
me he's not too happy
her opponent you look at what happened
in paterson new jersey you look at what
happened in virginia you look at what
happened
there's not a race and these are small
these are easy to control
now they want to send out of course the
counter factual is that entire states
have been voting exclusively by mail for
years and there's no problems whatsoever
i like the word unsolicited and
solicited so listen it's okay
because that's when you're asking and
you want it
then you send in the necessary paperwork
and documentation and you get the ballot
and you fill it out
that's okay but you can't this whole
thing with the
unsolicited unsolicited means you're
sitting there you know we have a big
enthusiasm edge
but when they throw these things in your
face and the lists are inaccurate
and people are dead and don't say you
should really go
out of your way to vote nobody should
make it easy for you to vote that's how
he wins by it being tough to vote
and they say i'm right behind the closed
doors
and it's a disgrace what they do to our
country 80 million
unsolicited ballots people that had no
idea
people that weren't going to vote in all
fairness that number doesn't pass the
sniff test only about 125 million people
vote in total
and the idea that two-thirds are going
to receive unsolicited ballots it
doesn't pass the sniff test
much like everything else that's being
said here i hope you all realize that
guy walks and then i'll have somebody
knock on the door say listen we'd like
your battle and i don't want to vote i
don't care about by
i'm a democrat i don't care about this
guy well look where is it here
take it blah blah blah they even have a
provision
where you don't have to verify
signatures what is going on
and they have another provision in some
states
where you can harvest that's where you
grab them all together and drop them
yeah that's something that's been done
by republicans almost exclusively to
manipulate results like what happened in
north carolina in 2018.
if we have a close selection funny all
of this stuff that they say somebody
might be motivated to do x
somebody could be motivated to do y it
barely happens and when it does it's
republicans
but if we have a close election that
means nevada has the right to and i love
nevada i think we're going to win nevada
except
where they're sending all these hundreds
of thousands millions
of unsolicited ballots to people
in nevada and people that probably left
a long time ago it's very unfair it's a
very unfair
but think of it they have seven days
after the election did you know that
mike
seven days what does that mean i want to
see the results of the election
on november 3rd right
and by the way if it's anything like
these other events it could go on
forever
yeah i mean the congressional it won't
it'll take a few days
that's it you know which they should not
have done they should make that do a
do-over and i think in patterson they
have a do-over i think they're going to
do it over because it was just
ripe with fraud theft people were
selling ballots
people were selling ballots and you know
they talk about russia
they're so worried about russia what
about sending out 80 million ballots
that's your real problem
and you know if russia or china or these
other countries want to cheat all they
have to do is forge ballots it's much
easier than
the way they have to go check out my
video clip about william barr
being asked about this idea of printing
ballots in china
uh it's on my youtube channel right now
it's it's quite interesting
you know that right and
we have two judges we have a state judge
we have a federal judge
i think both highly qualified judges
from what i understand i hear that uh
they're not too happy about what they're
seeing so we'll see what happens we're
going to see what happens
the lawyers feel very confident but we
have to win those cases
but what you have to do is send in your
early ballot
and then go and make sure that ballot is
tabulated or accounted
and if it's not counted vote
okay and then they have the job notice
trump's being
careful with his language yesterday he
suggested go try to vote twice
which is a felony to do and it's a
felony to incite someone to do
tonight he's being a little more careful
with the language people they'll be lost
they'll be gone the numbers are
incredible where they're 25 and 30
off 20 off follow your ballot
when i banned travel from china biden
called it hysterical and xenophobic
new time we had listened to sleepy joe
hundreds of thousands of more americans
would have died you know that you know
he's always
he always gets up today covert 19
covent i said joe
we got out of the country and i agree
with that
and we've done a hell of a job we've
done a hell of a job if you look at some
of our numbers
but you got to start talking about the
economy and you got to start talking
yours your place i mean this is a when
you look at pennsylvania
you're in a shutdown you think anybody
leaves these rallies and goes
you know phil that was really great it
was really good when trump talked about
china
really he's just such a great president
have a governor that has you
shut down
that's right and almost all states are
open
and frankly their numbers are very good
you're looking it'd be funnier for
people to leave and go
you know blanche that that was [ __ ]
we can't vote for this guy
yeah yeah we can't vote for him okay
good
you haven't even opened up the great
commonwealth
[Music]
well you have the same thing in north
carolina and you have the same thing in
michigan
what she's doing to michigan has said
and you know
you have death with a shutdown you have
depression you have drugs and alcohol
you have sickness you have loss of jobs
and people
you have suicides don't even think about
it but you have suicides
you have a tremendous there's actually
at this stage we did the right thing
we closed the country down we studied it
we learned about it
we know the susceptible or there
shouldn't be more than another hour of
this
since nursing homes people that are old
especially if they have
heart problems or if they have diabetes
we know that we learned it and we opened
it up
but the problem the shutdowns are
causing much bigger problems
you remember my original statement right
the cure can't be greater you know it
was an original statement that
a lot of people picked up but it's so
true you
have to open up this commonwealth it has
to be opened up
it has to be opened up now open it
but here's what i think they're doing
because you have the same thing in new
york we have a governor in new york
who's
36 000 people died 11 000 people in
nursing because he made a mistake
he made a horrible mistake and i built
him a convention center with 2
800 beds that they didn't use it and i
sent up a ship
a great hospital ship a massive hospital
with
hundreds and hundreds of rooms and they
didn't use it and he requested it
and then i said you're not using it why
aren't you using it he could have put
those people in the convention center in
the hospital ship what a shame
but you look at new york the restaurants
are all closed it's so sad for me
i love new york you know i grew up in
new york i love new york i did well in
new york
and it's so sad when i look at what's
happening with new york it's all
politics
if you kill somebody they don't
prosecute you there you go they go after
political enemies it's a terrible what's
happening in new york is a terrible
thing and the place is dead trump
complains that in new york if you kill
someone they don't prosecute you
meanwhile he says nothing about the kid
who killed two people in kenosha
lose their jobs they're never going to
open again it's not like the restaurants
is the greatest business in the world
it's a hard business
new york is closed you're closed
north carolina's close michigan all
democrats and let me tell you what's
going to happen
on november 4th they're going to
announce their opening they're doing
this
for political reasons for political
reasons
crowd delayed applause there because
even they don't believe it i'll raise it
because they want our numbers to look as
bad as possible
going into november third election day
and then as soon as the election's over
with winless he's accusing democrats of
wanting
people to die so that it's good
politically that is
insane and nobody wants that open you'll
be open on november 4th but you know
what
from your standpoint it's very close for
the election it's very far
if you have a restaurant then you can't
open your restaurant you can't open your
store
it's a disgrace and they ought to get
together they ought to do it
these are democrat governors
in all instances and democrat mayor
when the china virus arrived we launched
the largest national mobilization since
world war ii
thanks to the life-saving therapies that
we've pioneered the mortality rate
it's jarring when he goes back to
reading the script think of that
and we've achieved among the lowest case
fatality rates
of any major country anywhere in the
world you never hear that from the fake
news they don't want to talk to you
about it
and this is a big country this is a
tougher country to
do that with the european union's case
fatality rate is nearly three times
higher than ours
and if you look now spain is having a
big blow up
france is having a big blow up no we've
done a great job we haven't been given
credit for it and he always starts off
covid19 the u.s is a great place to be
stuck during coronavirus right guys what
about jobs what about all the other
things we have to do
all he does he thinks it's a weak spot
and actually in theory if we're getting
a fair shake from those people back
there
it's actually what the job we've done is
actually a strong spot
and that includes you people can you
imagine saying coronavirus is an area
you've excelled in now fortunately the
people aren't falling for it coronavirus
regularly ranks as
the most important issue for the
election and the one on which trump is
most underwater so so
thankfully people aren't falling for it
united states think of that
you don't hear these numbers cases in
the u.s
have declined by 28 percent nationwide
over the last month
and hospitalizations and deaths have
declined
radically over the last week three
vaccines are in final
stage of clinical trials would have
taken two years for
another president
i was going to say a normal president
but they'll hit me with a little truth
to that too
no but for another president especially
you know the last
administration they had the h1n1
pandemic it was called swine flu you
know
the n1h1 he gets it mixed up no
it's the h1n1 joe not that it matters i
guess
no do you ever notice he's always
calling it the other he calls it the
opposite he has no clue where he is
but he keeps saying oh if he was well he
didn't want to ban
china and we saved hundreds of thousands
of lives by banning china i was the only
one that wanted to do it actually
and then we banned europe because i saw
what was happening in italy and
spain and france and we banned europe we
saved hundreds of thousands
and if i didn't do the closing and the
opening so we're at 175
000. far too look one is too much route
199 it was given to us by china and it's
a disgrace
to disgrace they could have stopped it
they stopped it it's funny he laughed at
michelle obama for stating the wrong
number of deaths during her speech at
the dnc and he just understated deaths
by 15 thousands weird
got the worst marks you've ever seen for
his handling
of the h1n1 untrue about two-thirds of
the country approved of the obama biden
handling of h1n1 and
as you all know in a country this
polarized it's hard to get 66 percent of
people to agree on anything
he said we did a horrible job he said
they got lucky
it's not contagious like this we got
this is a tough one
i can look at that guy he'll catch it
right there and he's very far away from
me
it's by the way it's crazy how many
people are getting banned for
anti-semitism and racism in the chat
both twitch and youtube it's weird
nothing's easy about
that pandemics or epidemics
and his marks take a look at the job
they did
it was so bad that their top person
criticized it and they went after him
they said don't ever say that again
but it's a little late he said it was
one of the worst jobs
and we actually had a gallup poll where
we got very high marks for the job we
did
and so that is completely untrue donald
trump's approval on coronavirus is in
the toilet
obama biden approval on h1n1 was about
two-thirds of the country
we've done a great job and i don't want
credit but i
want the people mike pence gov k what
our vice president that was a glitch
right there
mike pence and
the task force headed up by mike and
working along with a lot of great people
they've done a fantastic job and they
just get
no credit if i was uh a democrat
a different president and they did the
same trump's schedule to depart in five
minutes just so you guys know
take a look at what they say about the
way they handled the swine flu
it was a disaster it was incompetent
they called themselves incompetent they
called themselves and now they're coming
in like well we would have done this
and biden by the way was totally against
you remember xenophobic
races because i closed down china
and then two months later two and a half
three and nancy pelosi was having
dances in chinatown right a month later
no no problem i was way ahead
then biden comes out and he actually
said that i was right but they said
don't say that
try doing it a little softer than that
so he did it a little bit softer
but we were right they were wrong they
handled it so badly
just take a look because we i said to my
people
we've got to fight this a little bit
differently because we're getting a lot
of
fake news a lot of bad people even
people who like this guy
you know you have to wait at these
things for hours before the president
ever shows up
even if you like trump you can't
possibly be saying
i want another half hour of this i want
another hour of this right it was a
disaster by cuomo
if you took new york out of those
numbers we would have numbers that would
be
even better than they are i could read
numbers that would be even much better
because a big percentage that died in
this country
died because new york was incompetently
run
by mayor de blasio and governor cuomo
and by the way just today there's
another
incredible thing happening pfizer great
company announced that it expects to
have
the results of its vaccine trials in a
matter of weeks very shortly incredible
under operation warp speed we remain on
track to produce a safe and effective
vaccine in that record time that we
talked about this would have been years
later
it will be delivered before in my
opinion before the end of the year but
it really might even be delivered
before the end of october how convenient
that would be
that'll be nice and you know why not
because of the election be nice because
we want to save people
oh be nice i see that's the important
thing together
i see we will defeat the virus the job
we're doing
is the job that all of the people
working on it are generals our admirals
the distribution we bought billions and
billions of dollars of things and now we
make
gowns and we make masks and we make
shields
and we make ventilators very tough the
ventilator is very complicated very
big very expensive tough ventilators
it's like i made the
statement it's like building a car but
more sophisticated they said no it's not
and they said they took a ventilator
they took it apart
these people are the worst the worst
over the next four years
we'll make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all
that's what we're doing plasma really
should be mentioned
and let me just tell you something if
they didn't waste
a year and a half of my life on a
ridiculous
impeachment based on a phone call that
was the waste of time
was because senate republicans never
even seriously considered the case that
was made
that was the wasted time it would have
all been done
and yet with all of the stuff the fake
russia witch hunt the fake ukraine
how about that did anybody read the
transcript of that call it was a perfect
call
hey congratulations good luck it was
like a perfect call now they'll take it
back and they'll say well i don't know
this was a perfe in history there's
never been anything like this
it was a totally lopsided 100
perfect political witch hunt and it goes
on
and on these are bad people i really
believe
they don't love our country i watch
nancy pelosi
you must wear your mask you have to wear
your mask
and we're going to keep every beauty
salon closed in california and all over
the
here we go and then i see a picture i
say
nancy pelosi well where's a mess
and i'll tell you what she must have
treated that beauty salon owner pretty
badly she uses the salon and the salon
turned her in
the salon turned her in
it is weird
i don't think i would have turned her in
i would have said well you know
she's a customer i got to take care of
my customers right
but she made them open and the salon
turned her in
and the salon did business with her how
much do they
hate nancy pelosi
and then she made a terrible mistake
because you want people that can't be
set up
she said i was set up i was set up
by the salon owner i was set up i said
tell me she didn't say that
why is he screaming so i just put out
that
if she was set up then she shouldn't be
leading
the house of representatives
i want the salon owner
to lead the house of representatives
because what
she set up think of it she set up the
speaker of the house
that was a big mistake as soon as i
heard she said well she set me up nancy
you're not supposed to get set up you're
representing our country
you know what she should have done
honestly trump's never been set up like
when kim jong-un played him like a
fiddle
this is like the biggest story this is a
big crazy nancy
highly overrated person let me just say
she is a highly overrated person
they give her such good play she is a
highly overrated person look
they just turned off a camera because
they don't want me saying that
obviously that's not true
so just in closing finally we will
rapidly return to full employment
soaring wages and
record prosperity we will hire more
police
increased penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
surge federal prosecutors into high
crime communities and banned sanctuary
cities
now why didn't he do these things during
his first term i wonder
who believe in enforcing the law not
their own political agenda
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten
our citizens we will not let them
threaten our citizens
and we will keep america out of endless
foreign wars
we will end surprise medical bill
we don't want surprise medical billing
you don't what happens it's terrible
but we have ended it and also we've
signed something that's incredible
you're going to see
some people say it's bigger than
healthcare and i signed it
unfortunately it takes place on january
1st you better elect me is he saying he
has signed things that are hidden until
january 1.
it's called price transparency
that's the drug price thing that he said
won't take take effect for months
[Music]
i said to my people the other day when
is price transparency this is going to
lower your prices by 50
you'll be able to negotiate you'll be
able to do things you're not even
allowed to do now with hospitals with
doctors
you get better doctors you get lower
prices i said when does it start
and it's a complicated oh did i get i
was fought you have no idea
right fellas you were fought too but
they fought me on this
price transparency it's bigger than
health care could be bigger than health
care
but i said when does it start it's not
bigger than health care
let me give you guys that preview very
first i said i better win this election
it's true
because you're going to see some
unbelievable price reductions and that
includes on
drugs because we're reducing health
insurance premiums massively and the
cost of prescription drugs went down the
first time in fact
it's completely untrue that premiums
have gone down you can find
absolutely no evidence at all
that that has taken place they're
killing me with ads they have nothing
but cash they have nothing but money
and they're spending because they can't
believe you know germany and other
countries pay much
less than we do and we want to have
what we have to have is we have to have
a comparison of prices
and that's what it's called favorite
nations laws i instituted a favor
so if we're paying 2.50 cents for a pill
and some nation is paying 10 cents for
the same exact pill
from the same factory right we get the
10
price so what's going to happen that'll
go up ours will come way down
they can't believe it
if that were true it would be really
great bettors is here our chief of staff
[Music]
they want to negotiate they called we
signed it it's all done
they want to negotiate and they are
negotiating so
uh let's see what happens but we're
going to get you cuts on prescription
drugs the likes of which you've never
seen
will protect medicare and social
security they will not be able to
protect it it will always protect
patients with pre-existing conditions
always
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars
when i took over nasa was dead now it's
the most vibrant space center in the
world by far
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and will that's scary what
do you guys think that means patriotic
education
our history and always respect our great
american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our
national motto in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
it really is mango mussolini it really
is a good term
for the great people of pennsylvania
from pittsburgh to harrisburg from erie
to easton
and from bethlehem to right here in
arnold palmer's beloved latrobe i love
arnold palmer
i don't know where i was we love arnold
there was only one arnold we stand on
the shoulders of pennsylvania patriots
who gave their blood
sweat and tears for this beloved nation
pennsylvania is the state where our
founding fathers declared
american independence right right
declared american independence
add the word commonwealth in there this
way they won't curtis
it's where the army weathered its brutal
winter at valley forge
and where general george washington who
by the way
they want all of the name washington
removed from everything
that's a lie guys i haven't been keeping
up with it what did he do
george washington they want the name off
congressman are we okay sean i don't
think you like that idea too much
well he owned slaves if trump doesn't
know but you know everybody did at the
time
but we'll keep it i promise you this
as long as you have cancelled culture
you better have a strong president
cancel culture
george washington can you believe it but
he led his men on a daring mission
across the delaware
this is the commonwealth where our union
was saved
by the heroes of gettysburg and where
generations of tough strong pennsylvania
workers
mind the call work the railroads
you you have to imagine that someone
behind the scenes probably goes listen
you know mr president rather than doing
two hours do like a really strong 40
minutes
and uh it'll just be way better in
general and don't scream you know just
do a solid 40 minutes high energy but
not going crazy
you think he just dismisses it or you
think people are too scared to even
suggest it
and together we are taking back our
country from these very
very deranged people we are returning
power to you the american people
with your help and your devotion and
your drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning wow
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious nation
under god god bless america will soon be
thriving like never before
next year will be the greatest economic
year
in the history of our country right
and together we will
work very hard the people of
pennsylvania the great great people of
pennsylvania where i went to college
it's a place i know very well
but we will make america wealthy again
we will make america strong again we
will make america proud again
we will make america safe again and we
will make america great again
thank you thank you
all right indistinguishable from parody
ending the jobs of anybody working in
satirical comedy
saturday night live could do nothing
with it my friends
it is another rally in the books for
donald trump
even even ymca part of the
impossible to parody nonsense
yeah um wow
ladies and gentlemen completely
unbelievable
donald trump speaking for how long was
that
trump speaking for about an hour and 33
minutes about 93 minutes
even longer than that completely
deranged republican national convention
speak
unbelievable listen guys thank you for
joining me if you are watching on twitch
please follow me we're trying to get to
those 50 000 followers on twitch and of
course if you're watching on youtube
please i you need to show that subscribe
button
no mercy we are only 17
000 away from a million the biggest
milestone we could imagine 17 000 away
from a million
if you're headed out as i am quite
frankly uh please hit that
subscribe button on youtube thanks to
the 37 of you
who grabbed memberships on my website
during the stream
consider grabbing one now at
joinpackman.com
it's been a real party couldn't imagine
anything more exciting
than seeing donald trump rant for 93
minutes while sweating profusely and
telling
hundreds of lies literally hundreds of
lies
we will see everybody very very soon
you